congressman ruben gallego or ruben
gashego as
i would say in argentina is a democratic
congressman representing the 7th
congressional district in
arizona and he joins me today
congressman to start with
we're we're down to the last few days
here in this election
um i i actually agree with donald trump
when he repeats that this is
the most important election he can
remember i i happen to agree i think i
disagree
on what the the outcome should be um
different people
putting different weight on poles that
look good for joe biden and poles that
look
not not quite so good what's the right
approach over the last few days here
well the right approach is for us to
just run through the tape that's what
joe biden's telling us
that's what we learned from 2016. we
can't really let up
uh i'm in a sling state here in arizona
florida is also swing state as everybody
knows uh this thing could come down to
just a couple thousand votes
and if it if not maybe this ends up
being a blow up but that's even a better
scenario so let's hope it to blow up but
in the meantime let's prepare for the
worse uh let's run all the way through
the tape
get everybody every last vote out that
we can uh and you know
there is going to be an attempt for this
president to manipulate the outcome of
the election
especially in the vote counting so the
larger the margin the harder it is for
him to do that
okay so we we know some of the tactics
that donald trump plans to use
including maybe even trying to get a
case
up to his new supreme court justice amy
coney barrett
we know about voter intimidation there's
all these different things that he could
do
joe biden on the other hand expecting
many of these
has lawyers ready but the offense only
needs one plan that the defense hasn't
accounted for so what what are we to do
how can we be prepared for any
eventuality
well i think the most important we could
do is if you have a ballot just turn it
in
do not wait for it to to go uh in the
mail
because if it comes afterwards they're
gonna try to discount it if you have a
ballot just walk it into the con
recorder right now
there's nothing within any any purview
of the law that they could come up with
that would stop
a ballot that was delivered to your
county recorder or the secretary of
state's office whatever it was
before election day uh afterwards
unfortunately they will try to litigate
um you know ballots that came afterwards
even if your state allows it
we can't trust this supreme court we
already saw
kavanaugh issued a very loose and flimsy
argument for why
election day should be over on election
day which has never happened i don't
know what the hell he thought was going
on
uh in the 1800s when we didn't have uh
in 1900s we didn't have instantaneous uh
counting all across the country
uh so but we can't take any chances so
please just return your ballot tell your
friend your families
to go and drop off their ballot uh
instead of putting it in the mail
this is really important because early
when president
trump started to assail the reliability
of the post office
uh many of us said you know the post
office is more than well enough equipped
to handle
all of these ballots even if the volume
were to double triple
you look at the number of holiday cards
that are sent out this is this is really
nothing
and yet you and many others are now
saying
out of an abundance of caution because
we don't know
what legal arguments they might use
you're recommending people use a ballot
dropbox rather than
mailing the ballot that's correct and
scared that i even have to do that the
fact that we have to
take all these precautions in the united
states in the year of 2020
as it were some third world country uh
or some country that is being run by
some kind of like dictatorship
uh it's quite frustrating i shouldn't
have to worry about that
but the whole the whole republican party
is just corrupt uh as well as the
president as well as his nominees at the
supreme court
if this was just the president acting i
wouldn't be so worried about the fact
that he's corrupted the whole republican
party
and and department justice apparatus we
just can't take any chances
i i was increasingly i was initially
a very hesitant to say too much about
the idea of expanding the court or not
early in the nomination and confirmation
process of amy coney barrett
i i've since come around to the idea
that given control of the white house
senate and house of representatives
this is something that democrats should
pursue i don't find the slippery slope
argument credible that if joe biden does
it
if he were to win every president will
add seats to the supreme court
you have to have the house senate and
presidency to do it i think in many
situations the general public wouldn't
tolerate it
have you taken a position on the
expansion of the court now that we've
seen the confirmation of amy coney
barrett
in hypocritical fashion i'm open to it
um obviously
you know there's a lot of devil in the
details and and i'd like to see how they
start ruling but
to be honest i'm more leaning towards it
and here's a couple reasons why number
one
the constitution does not disallow it
right of course
you know and if you read the
constitution the whole constitution is
about checks and balances right
where a check on the the house in the
center supposed to be a check on the
executive executives would be
the check on the house and the senate um
but what is
and and the supreme court will be a
check on the executive as well
legislature so what is the check on the
um supreme court well there's two
options one impeachment which is a very
high standard to begin with or should be
a high standard
um or you have the power to reconstruct
the
the supreme court and the circuit courts
uh and i think
that is one of the options that we have
to take right now because we have an
activist court
that is supplanting uh you know
democracy and democratic values
and if that's the case then we have to
use the one uh toolkit
available in our in our toolbox which is
either reducing the court
putting term limits or just adding more
supreme court justices
and if there is you know this tip for
tatwell you know
there shouldn't have been a tip for tap
but the fact is that this has been
politicized in so many ways
first by the rejection of merrick
garland second by this rushing of
amico barrett so we might as well uh
just go full
uh full fully into this and fight it on
a full scale
i am um quite worried about regardless
of who wins but in particular if joe
biden wins
i'm worried about what might become a
violent situation
in different parts of the country i
think that if the president
were to claim that it was rigged that he
really won
and in particular if it's close if it's
a blowout for joe biden i don't think
that this is as likely but if it's close
and the president claims it was rigged
i'm worried about armed violence in the
streets am i
wrong to worry about that i don't think
you're wrong to worry about it but i
think at the end of the day we have to
stick to the one principle which is we
have to preserve democracy
and it's not you know a bunch of
overweight fat guys pretending to be in
the army
um you know are are not going to be able
to stop our democracy from going forward
and so this president can argue whatever
he wants
uh but on january 20th as soon as that
uh
our president vice president biden is
inaugurated he needs to be out of that
white house and he could
talk his run his mouth all he wants uh
but he will be out of that white house
uh
by volition or uh by force
uh and we have to all think about it
that way so let's not fear
you know uh these these so-called
militias i mean they're about
you know 30 to 40 big macs away all from
having heart attacks anyway
uh we need to just focus uh on winning
this election and then by january
uh 20th on inauguration day if he's not
out of there
uh out of the white house and he's not
claiming to be he needs to stop claiming
to be president
we follow him with treason charges and
we follow anybody else that's supporting
him
on coronavirus um by if joe biden wins
by the time he
takes office we will be either in the
middle of or even beyond
spike number three whether you call it a
wave or not it's certainly
we're experiencing the third spike right
now a lot of the things that should have
been done early
don't make any sense once we're a year
in so in other words
uh you know once it's completely
widespread the importance of contact
tracing goes down
we will be well into the development of
the vaccine etc
what exactly do you want joe biden to do
differently
as of january when it comes to the virus
well i think he's going to have to lead
by example that's going to be very
helpful to begin with number two
helping implement a nationwide mask
mandate
uh number three contract tracing will be
difficult but testing is still very
important
and making sure that we have uh testing
that is nationwide
uh and quick uh and then lastly of
course having
um a you know sufficient amount of ppe
for
our uh our hospitals our nurses and our
first responders
because they're going to end up being
doing a lot of this this grunt work
have you as a member of congress gotten
any
timelines that we may not have gotten as
the public with regard to
vaccination and distribution no we
haven't gotten any information
that you that the public is not privy to
and what do you have an expectation now
about what 2021 will look like
you know even if we get a uh a safe
vaccine i don't foresee us being able to
to spread it uh and and implement it
fast and far enough for us to have what
i would call a quote normal normal
uh 2021 i think we're going to see 2021
uh first of all if there's a vaccine
it's going to go to first responder it's
going to go to teachers it's going to go
to our
our seniors that are the most vulnerable
um and then
you know after that i think they'll
start moving along
lines but i think 2020 we should repair
ourselves by
again more social continuous social
distancing
uh putting on a mass mandate uh and uh
and then you know wait for that vaccine
to hit a congressman i so appreciate
your time today thank you so much
thank you